we're seeking feedback on three
infrastructure projects in this year's
draft annual plan
a new community hub is an exciting
addition to the regeneration area in
kaiapoi and a concept plan for the hub
was approved in the ltp along with
funding towards build costs
as the plan developed infrastructure
needed to prepare the site for the new
buildings changed significantly and the
budget needs to be increased
we're also seeking your feedback on
funding increases for stormwater work in
kaiapoi
through the government's shovel ready
fund the council received funding
towards stormwater and flood
improvements this work is essential to
prevent future flooding in kaiapoi
project costs were underestimated and
the cost of construction materials has
risen
this means that the council's
contribution of 50 of the total project
cost needs to increase so that we can
complete it within the government's time
frame
the final topic we want to talk to you
about is funding for road improvements
to fund our work program to upgrade
roads across the district we rely on
funding assistance from wakako tahi
in this funding round we were allocated
half of the cost this means we need to
re-prioritise our work program and focus
on smaller projects that keep our
communities safe
let us know what you think at
govt dot nz forward slash let's talk